okay right so my name is Raju I work at
cymatics my blue search consulting
they're also co-authoring elasticsearch
in action my use case for search engines
is indexing logs and by that I mean it
looks can be lots of stuff from server
logs and application logs and fiber logs
and that sort of stuff to metrics or
even social media data anything can be
that can be sort of stream say I like
big logs process them make them into
structure nice structured events and
index them into elasticsearch or solar
I've been working mostly with elastic
search for logs and that helps when you
want to search and analyze them in real
time and I want to ask you if you
already do stuff with your logs like
centralize them something like that do
you okay I get a show hands or something
okay so I guess I'll ask you about
certain technologies that III will talk
about right so this is also what we're
trying to do
with logs in his work with Nick already
said and what's on my agenda today is
talk about three really nice log
processing tools one is log stash one is
Apache room and one is our syslog and
then because logs tend to be pretty
right heavy I want to show you how I
would do elastic search and solar to
handle lots of Rights and how to end up
just a bit about scaling them out and in
the end I will show you a demo which is
not gonna be a live demo it's gonna be
like a screencast
when I pick our syslog and elasticsearch
and show you like the whole path
so all of the law processing tools that
I'm going to talk about I like them
because they can take take logs and
parse them if you have like unstructured
logs if they can parse them and you can
put you can make us out a structured
document like a JSON out of that you can
you can
yeah I'll say transform but it's more
about taking out data changing changing
stuff and they also offer you ways to
buffer your logs so if your search
engine cannot keep up with with the load
or there's this pipe in your logs then
buffering helps you deal with that and
then obviously deliver the logs the
search engine so the first two I want to
talk about is log stash and I want to
ask you if you already use log stash or
have heard of it okay right so so log
stash is is a tool that is very nice for
for connecting stuff like you have lots
of plugins so you can take logs from
lots of sources whether they're files or
over the network or various data stores
you can run them to various filters like
the most popular one being grog which is
like a rap over regular expressions it
makes it easy for you to use regular
expression to parser and structure logs
and make them structured and then you
have lots of outputs that that let you
forward
and if you zoom in a bit you know you
can have multiple inputs if you do that
each one runs on thread so they don't
block each other then you haven't went
to filter workers that can that do this
processing that you want to do
it gets each event through all the
filters that we define and then you have
a bunch of workers that work forward and
what I would like to use logstash for is
exactly that to connect a datastore to
another like if you want for example to
take Apache logs from from a file you
can tell that file you can process those
logs make them make them structures to
block and you can send them over to
elasticsearch or solar and if you if you
need buffering you can you can change
multiple log stash agents so for example
you can have on your server a log stash
agent that tails logs and puts them into
something like readies that can do the
buffering for you and then it can have a
different agent that pulls data from
Redis and index into elasticsearch or
solar the next two I want to talk about
is Apache flume is anyone they want to
heard of it or are using it okay so it
started as a way to channel your day
to HDFS and now it's more of a
multi-purpose to the main plugins that
you have our sources which lets you
channels is channels our way to to
buffer data you can do that on disk or
in memory and then things are way for
you to deliver data and you can process
the data in any way in the sense of
transforming it in a lot in lots of
places the way I like to do that is in
the sink and there's one particular
thing that does a very good job at
processing data
and this one is called more flying more
flying is is a library that allows you
to define some commands and then you can
run your your data through these
commands as before they were like pipes
so if vlogs are coming in then you can
you can have a command that reads one
line at a time or can match multi-line
logs into an event and then you can use
the graph command which is a port of
what logstash
can have a load solar command which
which will load then you lock the soul I
forgot to ask in the beginning if you
have any questions feel free to
interrupt me and I'd be really glad to
actually get some some feedback and
question so your your data flow through
flume doesn't have to be linear like one
source one channel one one sink you can
also do stuff like so you can bind one
source channels and from each channel
you can have one one sink so this allows
you to take your logs and for example
output them to HDFS and n solar this is
actually what I think Jim is very good
at if you need to to send your logs to
HDFS or solar or both I think this is
the best because it also has buffering I
think it's kind of your you can do
everything in one agent although you can
chain multiple agents if you want to the
last want to talk about is our syslog
Jules message modifiers and output
modules so you can for example take send
JSON over syslog you can parse the JSON
append some syslog metadata like a
hostname or severity and then take the
bigger JSON and index it into
elasticsearch our syslog also can do
buffering a couple of places there's
more action queues and the flow of data
comes from the input modules where we're
going to put messages into the main
queue then the main queue workers do
pretty much all the work they apply the
filters and whatever configuration logic
you have and then send messages over
into the action queues and the action
workers take stuff from the action
queues and put them into the destination
do you have a question you can also have
multiple such flows so one such flow can
be defined as a
more of them for example a rule set for
processing remote logs a different rule
set for processing and the nice thing
about access logs that it's optimized
for speed which is also what makes it
light at least on CPU on memory depends
on how much how big your queues are some
at performance as I said logs can be
very write heavy and it's a good idea if
you can send multiple logs to be indexed
in the same request so all the tools
that I've talked about can can do that
for you what they're sent to
elasticsearch or solar and when a
request is sent the the loading tool
typically has to to wait for the Verdean
exit to be done in order to get a reply
so it makes sense to have multiple
workers to do this stuff in parallel if
you want up to optimizing the search
engine to get more indexing throughput
if you need that one of the things that
is pretty important is how often soft
commits are done so
typically if at a certain interval the
searchers are refreshed so that newly
indexed data it gets visible in
searching and this operation is pretty
expensive so you can trade off some of
these freshness of the data with some
then there's the hard commit so
hopefully after searching solar
typically indexed stuff in memory and
when certain thresholds are met the
stuff that's indexed in memory gets
flushed into a leucine segment so this
operation is again quite costly so you
can tune though you can change those
thresholds to make them more or less
rare and once leucine segments are are
written to disk
they are immutable which means that you
can you can generate a lot of segments
and to keep the number of segments in
check there's an operation called margin
that happens asynchronously and that can
really fresh your your i/o and your CPU
so you can merge policy you have very
happy rights to allow for more segments
but this will come at the expense of
another thing that you can do is you can
have time-based indices or collections
so let's say you want to keep your logs
for a week you can have one index or
collection per day which is a bunch of
advantages all your indexing
the layers index which will be smaller
there will be less segments affected
less merges going on most of your
searching probably happens on recent
data so that should be faster as well
you can still search to multiple indexes
or collections and you can also this
design also allows you to delete entire
indices which is much faster than
deleting individual documents from
within and in there and blast searches
over ability is to create and they both
offer you aliases so you can you can
make an alias that points to one index
or to multiple indices and you can use
those Alice's from your application to
make it easier thing
finally if one server is not enough you
can scale out with the last fixer this
is pretty easy because the elasticsearch
clusters by default you start more node
they form a cluster I either discovering
each other through multicast or two
unicast and they elect a master and
charge typically charge the value for
balance across your cluster solar you
have to use zookeeper there's an
embedded zookeeper you can use a
independent zookeeper and that's where
your cluster information gets stored and
also where your collection set in this
get stored so I promised the demo I will
show you
so now the first thing I'm doing is
putting a new index I'm using time basis
so let's say what makes for that day
and then I'm making an audience from
that index and I will call it the latest
index
to show you my excess flow configuration
the first part is about loading the
modules I will use there is one that
allows me to receive logs over TCP in
there is one that asked me to send them
over to elasticsearch then I start the
listener on for one 35.4 and then I have
a main queue which will be memory this
is where where my love will be buffered
and I will have to work too many queue
workers working on it and you will the
batch size there means that each worker
will take a batch of a thousand events
and process them and then shove them
over to the action views
and this is my template this is how the
JSON that end up ends up in elastic
searches is built if you squint a bit
you will see that for each property the
actual property that will get you in
there
the finally the reaction when I refer to
the template of justifying oops
you claim
so the action is before the template
I've just defined it's going to the
latest index it is in my alias and it's
selling book to 5,000 messages with five
workers in the last account is basically
telling us not to retry if the last
research is not available if we tried
now I'm going to start our system to the
movie star
go to my
just fight through them over to speed
mrs. cabana have you heard of it or used
it hey it's a really nice tool to
visualize histogram that shows you how
many logs I'm just going to wait for for
the indexing rate to stabilize the plan
is to apply some optimizations and see
how the indexing rate
in this case I have really seen laptop
this one it's pink a software speaking
all right
Yeah right and you will be in after the
optimization changes right yeah that's
exactly right so this is the cool thing
my elasticsearch is you have lots of
nice easy eyes and one of them allows
you to update your index settings on the
fly and this is what I'm doing here I'm
increasing the Refresh interval from the
default one second to ten seconds
I'm also increasing the threshold of how
many operations to get indexed in memory
until there's a flash to a Phoenix in
the original city was 5,000 I have 1
million the most quality I'm getting
technics worked here instead of the
default 10 seconds per few so this this
will allow for more segments and this
should help it works
we'll take a minute
the plan was to explain those cities
while the movie was running
definitely
yes yes so following one refresh you
will get I'm just gonna pause for a bit
so the question was what's the question
again sorry Oh what does the refresher
it means that every 10 seconds
the every 10 seconds elastics that will
refresh the view of the index so that
means the the logs that get indexed
between two refreshes are not available
for search until the next refresh
campaign is that answer your question
what's the default value of the Refresh
interval if one second there's actually
a blog post on our blog where I do
benchmarks with I think the default
value in 10 seconds and 30 seconds
something like that and show how the
indexing rate varies with that so yeah
there's the trade-off and I guess it
depends on
what you need so you can see now don't
be mixing with raises to the second so
there's like 50 it's pretty significant
yeah this is basically God got the whole
million logs index right there so on I
just want to show you another screencast
which is about
this is elasticsearch head it's a nice
plugin or you can just download it from
github and just open the view web page
and you're gonna connect your cluster
and you will show you you know so here
you can see I have three nodes and I
have one index called log stash that one
and I have three shots and each node has
one shard and this is the latest alias
that points this log stash in there
because the three nodes
refresh you can see join our cluster but
it cannot get any data because you only
have three sharks so this is where it's
nice to use time Beijing this is because
you can you have the opportunity every
day or every time interval to create a
new index with a different number of
sharks so now we are all mode we can
create a an index with four sharks and
the next step is to click the the latest
alias from the old index to the new one
and the operation basically consists on
removing the yes that was pointing to
the old index and putting up new areas
let's bring to the new one in the same
operation
so now Venus is pointing to the name and
that's pretty much it
we're hiring worldwide - interesting
that's about it if you have any
questions we really have to cancel them
so the question is once the logs are in
if there ways to program and program
area analyze something not just
visualized tools I'm not sure what you
mean by that right
sanely like Howie how you can monitor
certain metrics for example you can do
like analytics and then you want to
trigger something some events well I
guess you can use the api's the Search
API to do all the stuff and then you can
you can do that from your script or
monitoring - or whatnot - to send the
other actor to whatever action
okay
yes
right right
I'm not sure how you can do that I guess
you can search for such I mean how how
do you want to correlate like you want
to see whether those two events happen
in the same timeframe or what if you can
if you want to do that then you can just
search for you can run a search and you
can see in the search can say does did
this exception happen or did this
exception happen so both events if they
happen in that time frame you can also
specify time frame as the criteria so if
both exception happened in that time
frame they'll both pop up
sorry HD can integrate HDFS with
elasticsearch I know there is one
integration but I didn't really use it
so I think the answer is yes
sorry
and don't understand the question can
you speak close to the microphone okay
doesn't have anything about what
authentication right right okay well I
think the common practice here is to put
something some proxy like in nginx on
front of over elasticsearch and and hit
that and then you can do authentication
and you can also restrict users to URLs
I can bet there are other methods
longer slugs -
ha
well what I like about flume is that it
can do pretty much everything it has
buffering it has all those processing
things so if you need like to do
everything in like have tight
integration and do everything in one
place then I guess Plumas is the one to
choose log stash on the other hand is
very very flexible it has a ton of
plugins and you can write plugins very
easily if you need something new so if
it's flexibility that you want if you
want to connect things stop by things
log stash is something I use for that
analytics in body mean by analytics
I think this is so so the question sorry
alert and exception yeah this is this is
something that you can do log stash you
can say if message matches a certain
pattern for example you would deliver it
to a certain output and that output
could be on a Dios plug-in that would to
make your send an email or something
like that if you want to do counts this
sort of aggregations I think this is
something that's either being worked on
or it's already possible but I think
this is useful for when you have small
amounts of data ideas or when you just
want to compact like for sending metrics
and you want to send home to
elasticsearch only the the average from
seconds if you want to do aggregations I
think they're best done on the
elasticsearch side
hi
yes
for now it's not building I'm not sure
if it's intended to be building they
have like really small cues like 20
messages cues that different threads
used to tell each other but the point is
that you should use like the best tool
for the job
and yeah that's the philosophy I think
and so you can use something different
with their edges you can use regular cue
or something like that yes
how do filters how can they be
configured well the typical pattern is
you would you would label every input
with the tag so for example if logs are
coming through TCP they have
participated if they're coming from file
sorry
wait a minute you're not talking about
logstash
oh yeah well we'll look stache only has
inputs filters and outputs flume has
channels so the typical pattern is you
would have one or more sources like
let's say you're tailing Apache logs and
you're also taking your sis logs and you
would you would tag them you'd say this
input adds the apache tag and this one
it has the syslog tag and then lower in
your configuration you want to define
filters you say if the event has an
Apache tag then you would apply the grog
filter with the Apache pattern and this
will do that if you have the syslog you
will apply the seasonal patterns and
then pour them onto the outputs on which
language
it looks like a ruby but it's I don't
think it's like the full Ruby it's just
like configuration for man you say say
filter and then like yes
yeah hash is probably they look like
hashes to me I'm not
welcome
any more questions
okay you can you can catch me later
thank you very much for coming